ما انت غبا شمس اربيل حتى تبداوا الحياه
الليليه في شارع الاسكان وسط المدينه
ويمتاز هذا الشارع بكثره محله التجاريه
والمطاعم فضلا عن المقاهي التي يقصدها
السياح المحليون القادمون من محافظات وسط
وجنوب العراق ليقظوا اوقاتا ممتعه حتى وقت
السحور شارع الاسكان هذا شارع 24 ساعه
فاتح كلهم مزدحم كل المطاعم كافيهات شيم
وناسه نتونس الواحد يغير جو يعني الاسكان
مكان
راحه نفسيه واكل وشرب وكل عام وانتم بخير
يا رب
نرحب بكل الوافدين وكل محافظات العراق
وتنمو الحركه في شارع الاسكاني خلال شهر
رمضان بشكل مختلف فيصبح الشارع مقصدا
للباحثين عن التسليه والترفيه وملاظا
لرواد المقاهي
لعبه شعبيه تراثيه قديمه
عصرناها لعده اجيال من
ثمانينات وتسعينات لعبناها وكان كنت العب
بفريق نادي الكاظميه ويا استاذي جاسم
الاسود
وهي الغايه من اللعبه ودوا محبه وتعارف
سوق اربيل ليلي تكثر فيه محل لبيع
الماكولات السريعه فضلا عن الحلويات
والمكسرات والشاي العراقي المجهز على فحم
الخشب والذي يزداد الطلب عليه في ليالي
رمضان من قبل رواد هذا الشارع
احمد الحمداني العربيه اربيل
لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار رامز والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات